so die erste Frage kanntest Du ja schon
aber kannest kennst du das hier nee das
ist
Fragenlotto das sind das sind Fragen die
Grünen sind harmlose Fragen zal wie Fan
sich stellen würde und die die roten
sind da uns das gemeinste ausgedacht was
uns so eingefallen
ist ich hoffe ich weiß nicht ob es
gemein genug
ist mal
sehen handgemacht voll
cool okay schmeiße mal die Fitze in
meine hosenfalte okay da liegen sie
gut warum hast du das Auto
geklaut na ja also es stand im
Drehbuch ja aber wie wie ist es zu dem
Drehbuch gekommen hast du da kein
Mitspracherecht se ja eine fiktive
Geschichte ja keine Dokumentation ja
wobei du das ist ja ein Song von dir du
bist ja Lena in dem Video jeder denkt du
bist
Lena ja nee nee also ich bin Lena in der
Situation in der man performt ach so und
in der anderen Situation ist Fiktion ah
ja okay und in der
fiktionslena da kann man alles machen ja
ah ja okay und das ja auch nur
ausgeliehen aber nur das sah nicht wie
ausgeliehen aus nachdem das Dach ab war
nein das ist nur
ausgeleden
okay der schöne Kadett ich habe geweint
ja der war wirklich schön
schon mal über Tanzunterricht
nachgedacht ja ich habe seit meinem
sechsten Lebensjahr Tanzunterricht ich
tanze Ballett und Jazz auch HipHop
manchmal
showdce Problem ja aber ist natürlich
dass ich auf der Bühne keine
Choreografie oder vorgegeben Tanzstil
präsentiere quasi
sondern
intuitiv aber da sieht man den J nicht
unbedingt immer nee nee soll man ja auch
gar nicht Gegenteil es gibt ein
Musikvideo von also ein Video von
musikvide Dreh von satellite und da
machst du einen Ausfallschritt der
heftig diskutiert ist da hast du de Fuß
so rechtwinklig angezogen und trittst du
raus und es sieht so ein bisschen wie
Gummistiefel Tanz als hätst du
Gummistiefel an aus ja das sind die
imaginären Gummistiefel die habe ich
immer an die fallen nur das sind
durchsichtig kenne ich gar nicht das
Video guck da muss mal gucken ist
ziemlich viel geklickt geht auf eine
Million zu
nächste rote Frage immer die roten
suchen auch Leute die Grünen sich raus
die meisten nehmen die roten komisch ne
ja müsstet dir mal auf verppeln und
sagen die roten sind die Bösen und dann
steht in den grünen Deck das ist aber
langweilig ich glaub die Grünen die sind
auch so
harmlos kannst ja mal eine grüne
versuchen
gleich das ist aber gut das ist mal eine
gute Frage warum redest du so ungern
über dein Privatleben hast Du was zu
verbergen oder hast du keins so keins
von beiden ich habe ich rede nicht über
mein Privatleben weil ich
ähm weil ich finde dass das der Begriff
an sich schon äh schon erklärt privat
ist nicht öffentlich und ähm ich
unterscheide da zwischen meinem
Privatleben was meine Person angeht und
dem Privatleben was mein Umfeld angeht
ja ich sag immer das eine ist persönlich
und das anderes privat
richtig sehr sehr richtig wir wollen nur
persönliches
S von uns preis gebe so ich kann leider
nicht über anderen reden und jetzt werde
ich mal die nächsten grüne Fragen ne so
werden wir das mal
öffn mit die
getackete wie kommst du D zu dass di
alle Männer anschmackten
anschm
anschmachten ja allemach nicht an eine
Menge ja du jetzt z. nicht ich mach
schon
bisschen glaub es aber hackt i believe I
Spider
alles ich kriege das nicht so mit
ehrlich gesagt also ich habe nicht das
Gefühl dass da so unglaublich viele
Männer mich
anschmchen sondern was ist so in der
Fanpost
drin die meiste Fanpost kommt von 8 bis
14jährigen Girls aha so jetzt ist es
jetzt ist es raus noch ein ren noch eine
rote zum Abschluss zum Finale
okay haben deine Lehrer bei deinem
Abitur ein Auge
zugedruckt kann ich nicht beantworten
vielleicht mal die Lehrer fragen ach das
weißt Du nee weiß ich nicht ich h kein
Gefühl
dafür ich hab mich besser oder Sch
eingeschätzt nee eigentlich nicht also
da wo ich mich schlecht eingeschätzt
habe habe ich auch schlecht geschrieben
schön und da wo ich mich ganz okay
eingeschrieben schz habe ich auch ganz
okay
geschrieben also keine großen Schwankung
also die haben auch ke überall 14 Punkte
glaube ich Dir nicht was hast ja gesagt
du bist faul
ja
ne manchmal auch nicht manchmal auch
nicht ich wür so gerne dann wig die
anderen Fragen noch lesen mich dann
darüber kaputt lachen dass ich die dann
nicht beantworte ja das hat wir auch
schon ein paar mal aber meistens werden
dann beantwortet ja mal gucken kannst ja
ganz kurz
machen wie erhältst du deine Frische und
Natürlichkeit
Duschen wie hast du bei dem Stress ein
Abi gepackt
lernen
du vermittelst ein starkes
Selbstbewusstsein woher stammt das
Erziehung vielen Dank super
danke sehr
schön das war aber anstrengend aber ist
ein schönes Bild jetzt ist ein schönes
Bild dekorativ sehr
anschaulich